Planar homography
Now we will consider the case where a camera
is looking at a bunch of points and these
points all lie on a plane. The plane has got
its own co-ordinate system which we denote
by co-ordinate frame zero. Clearly every point
that lies on this plane has got a Z co-ordinate
of zero, which is shown down here. The co-ordinate
capital Z multiples all of the elements in
the third column of our camera matrix but
because it's zero we can effectively remove
that column from the matrix and we can remove
that row from the world co-ordinate vector.
What we're left with now is a three by three
matrix and we'll refer to this three by three
matrix as a "Planar Homography".
Just as for the camera matrix, there is an
arbitrary scale factor and once again we can
normalize the homography matrix by choosing
one particular element that we're going to
set to the value of one. So this three by
three matrix, it's got one element that we've
set to one, there are eight unique numbers
remaining in the homography matrix. And we
can estimate the homography matrix if we have
four world points and the corresponding position
of those points on the image plane of our
camera.
So the concept of corresponding points, imagine that I've got two planes, one is perhaps the
image plane of the camera, the other might
be a physical plane in the world that the
camera is looking at. Alternatively the first
could be a view of a plane in the world and
the second image could be another view of
the same plane in the world, where we've moved
the camera between the two views.
Now we've got four points in each of these
planes, which I'm going to denote by the subscripts
one through four and I'm going to arrange
the co-ordinates of those points into the
columns of a matrix. But what's really important
here is the ordering of these columns. We
have to ensure what's called correspondence.
P1 and Q1 must correspond to the same point
in the world and so it goes for P2, P3 and
P4. Each point P and the corresponding point
Q must refer to the same point in the world.
Let's look at a practical example of how we
can use this technique to perform something
called "Perspective Rectification". Now this
is a picture that I took of the Notre Dame
Cathedral in Paris.
It's a very tall cathedral, so I'm on the
ground in front, looking up and taking a picture.
And clearly because my camera is tilted upwards
I've got a very distorted view of the front
of the cathedral. But I know some things about
cathedrals and particularly I know that the
front of the cathedral is most likely to be
a plane.
So if I pick four points on the front of the
cathedral that I believe all lie in a single
plane and I can label them P1 through to P4.
But I know that those points in a non-distorted
image will form a rectangle in the image plane,
not a trapezoid. I can compute the image plane
co-ordinates Q1, Q2, Q3 and Q4 in order to
have a rectangle in the image. So if I have
now two sets of corresponding points; I have
the points P1 through P4 and I have the points
Q1 through Q4, then I can compute a homography.
So if I build up a matrix P that contains
as columns the points P1 through P4 and the
matrix Q, whose columns are the points Q1
through Q4, then I can compute a homography.
And it's shown here and very simple to do
in MATLAB. Now that I have this homography
matrix H, I can use it to transform any point,
P, in my original image, to any point, Q in
a second image.
And this is what the second image looks like.
We see that the cathedral has been straightened
up. We can see that the vertical edges of
the cathedral are in fact vertical lines in
the image. It's important to remember that
there's a very strong assumption made in this
process and that is that all of the points
in the image lie on a plane.
Certainly many of the points in this image
lay on the frontal plane of the cathedral,
but not all do. If we look at points around
here, which are on the edges of the bell towers,
then they do not lay on the frontal plane
and the transformation won't be correct for
them. It will introduce a distortion in that
part of the image. You can't get anything
for free, we've certainly proved that geometric
correctness of the bulk of the cathedral.
Given that I've computed the matrix H using
MATLAB, then it's a very simple matter to
apply the homography to every single point
in the image. And we perform that by a process
known as "Image Warping".
To do image warping, we can see that every
single pixel in the output image and the output
image in this case is the geometrically correct,
the rectified image of the cathedral.
To illustrate this I’m going to choose just
one particular point in the output image and
it’s the pixel at co-ordinate 600,100. Now
if I know that pixel co-ordinate, I want to
try and work out what's the corresponding
pixel co-ordinate in the input image.
The homography is a mapping from the original
image to the new image, so in order to map
this co-ordinate I need to use the inverse
of the homography and that gives me the co-ordinate
of the corresponding point in the input image
and it's got a co-ordinate of 757 and 51.
The way image warping works then is we go
and find the pixel at co-ordinate 757, 51
and we take that pixel value and we insert
it into the new image at co-ordinate 600,
100. So for every single pixel in the output
image, we work out where it comes from in
the input image.
You can see here that the co-ordinates in
the input image are fractional and that requires
a technique called image interpolation to
find what is the actual pixel value at this
particular fractional co-ordinate. In a nutshell,
that's the process of image warping.
Another application of image warping is this
often used effect now in swimming telecasts,
where we take the flag and the name of the
competitors and we overlay them on the lanes
of the swimming pool. It's actually quite
an easy trick to do and it involves these
homographies.
Now image that I could swim well, well enough
to get into a swimming tournament, so there's
my flag and there's my name. Now I've got
this image that I created, just using ordinary
computer graphics, that's the easy bit. Now
I want to lay that image into my lane in the
swimming pool. All I need to do that, is to
find the four corresponding points, so the
four corners of this rectangle that holds
the image that I want to overlay and the four
points in the swimming pool where I'd like
it to be laid.
Once I have that information I can warp that
original image into this very distorted image
which I could then insert into or overlay
onto the original image of the swimming pool.
Those of you who are doing the project associated
with this course, the homography is going
to be very, very useful. You've probably already
built a two dimensional robot, that sits on
a worksheet and can move its end effector
to any particular XY co-ordinate on the robot
worksheet.
Now image that we take a picture of that robot
worksheet. I have an image of the robot worksheet.
The homography lets me create a mapping between
a co-ordinate in the image of the worksheet,
which has got a co-ordinate of U,V in the
image plane and I can map that to a physical
co-ordinate, X,Y on the robot's worksheet.
I can map from an image plane co-ordinate
to a robot worksheet co-ordinate, or I can
map from a robot worksheet co-ordinate back
to a camera image co-ordinate.
Now homography's are going to be very, very
helpful for you in completing the project.
Just to summaries the capability in the toolbox
for computing and using homographies. Given
two sets of corresponding points P and Q,
we can compute a three by three homography
matrix. The columns of P and Q represent points.
Now P might be image co-ordinates of known
points in an image, Q might be co-ordinates
of points on the robot's physical worksheet.
Alternatively P could be a set of image co-ordinates
in one image and Q could be a set of image
co-ordinates in another image. Given that
I have the three by three homography matrix
H, I can then map a set of points P, in the
first plane, to a set of points Q, in the second plane.